A TERRORIST STATE.
THAT IS WHAT UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT WANTS RUSSIA TO BE
OFFICIALLY DECLARED AFTER A
HORRIFIC MISSILE STRIKE ON THE
CITY OF VINNYTSIA.
THIS SURVEILLANCE VIDEO,
SHOWING THE MOMENT RUSSIAN
MISSILES HIT THAT CITY ON
THURSDAY, KILLING IT LEAST 23
PEOPLE.
AND YOU COULD SEE PEOPLE
DUCKING FOR COVER.
THERE'S A MASS BLOWN OUT
WINDOWS IN THE BUILDING OF MORE
THAN 60 PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
AND, RESCUERS ARE STILL COMBING
THROUGH DAMAGED BUILDINGS,
LOOKING FOR MORE THAN 40 OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL MISSING.
PRESIDENT-ELECT, SQUEEZING,
LATER THAT RUSSIA HAS DONE WHAT
NO OTHER STATE WOULD.
>> [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[INTERPRETER]
THIS DAY HAS, ONCE AGAIN, PROVE
THAT RUSSIA MUST BE OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED AS A TERRORIST
THING.
NO OTHER STATE IN THE WORLD OF
POSES SUCH A TERRORIST THREAT
AS RUSSIA.
NO OTHER STATE IN THE WORLD
ALLOWS ITSELF TO DAILY DESTROY
PEACEFUL CITIES AND ORDINARY
HUMAN LIVES WITH CHRIS MISSILES
AND ROCKET ARTILLERY.
>> THE ORGANIZATION FOR
SECURITY AND COOPERATION IN
EUROPE SAYS, SOME RUSSIAN
ACTIONS IN UKRAINE MEET THE
CRITERIA OF CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY.
THE GROUP RELEASING ITS
SECONDARY REPORT ON THURSDAY,
AFTER ITS EXPERTS HAVE VISITED
BUCHA AND OTHER UKRAINIAN
CITIES.
THE DOCUMENT SAID THAT IT FOUND
CREDIBLE EVIDENCE SUGGESTING A
PATTERN OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
CIVILIANS, INCLUDING THE
DISCOVERY OF RUSSIAN TORTURE
CHAMBERS IN BUCHA.
>> EVIDENCE THAT DOZENS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS WHO WERE
GETTING RAPED BY RUSSIAN TROOPS
THERE, THE REPORT SAYS NINE OF
RUSSIAN MISSILE STRIKE IN
VINNYTSIA KILLED AT LEAST 23
PEOPLE AND WOUNDED DOZENS MORE.
CNN'S SCOTT McLEAN IS IN A
HOSPITAL IN VINNYTSIA WITH THE
LATEST.
SCOTT?
>> Reporter: JOHN, WE'VE BEEN
SPEAKING TO PEOPLE HERE, WE MET
THE FAMILY OF ONE MAN WHO WAS
INSIDE OF THAT CONCERT HALL AT
THE TIME THAT ONE OF THOSE
MISSILES CAME RAINING DOWN AND
EXPLODED.
HE WAS A TECHNICIAN WORKING ON A
CONCERT OF THE UKRAINIAN POP
SINGER WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE
HAD A CONCERT LAST NIGHT TO
RAISE MONEY FOR THE MILITARY.
HIS MOTHER AND HIS COUSIN TOLD
ME THAT HE HAS SEVERE INJURIES
TO HIS SPINE AND TO HIS CHEST.
WE SAW HIM JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO BEING ROLLED ON A STRETCHER
TO ANOTHER BUILDING AND HE LOOKS
LIKE HE IS FRANKLY IN VERY BAD
SHAPE.
THEY SAY THE NEXT FEW DAYS FOR
HIM WILL BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
HIS COUSIN TOLD ME THAT SHE
WANTS ALL OF RUSSIA TO DIE.
THOSE ARE HER WORDS.
NO ONE SPARED IS WHAT SHE TOLD
ME.
THAT'S HOW ANGRY SHE'S FEELING.
I ALSO SPOKE WITH THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WHO SAID THAT ALL BUT
TWO OF THE MORE THAN 100 PEOPLE
WHO SHOWED UP AT THIS HOSPITAL
WITH SHRAPNEL WOUNDS AND WITH
BURNS WERE CIVILIANS.
HE SAYS HE TREATS SOLDIERS FROM
THE FRONT LINES ALL THE TIME.
HE UNDERSTANDS WAR, HE
UNDERSTANDS MILITARY TARGETS BUT
HE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND THIS.
LISTEN.
>> Translator: I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE GOAL, TO SCARE
US?
THEY WON'T SCARE US.
BUT TO KILL CIVILIANS, IT'S
BEYOND A CRIME.
SOMETHING INHUMAN,
INCOMPREHENSIBLE.
>> Reporter: NOW, THE YOUNGEST
OF THE VICTIMS YESTERDAY WAS A
4-YEAR-OLD GIRL, HER MOTHER HAD
POSTED A VIDEO ON INSTAGRAM OF
HER PUSHING HER STROLLER DOWN
THE STREET, AN HOUR OR TWO LATER
SHE WAS LAYING DEAD NEXT TO THAT
STROLLER.
WE'VE LEARNED THAT THE FIRST
LADY OF UKRAINE HAD MET THIS
GIRL WHILE SHOOTING A CHRISTMAS
VIDEO WITH CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES JUST LAST YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT'S DEPUTY CHIEF OF
STAFF WAS AT THIS HOSPITAL
EARLIER THIS MORNING MEETING
WITH SOME OF THE VICTIMS.
I SPOKE TO HIM BRIEFLY AND HE
TOLD ME THAT HE ACTUALLY MET
WITH THIS YOUNG GIRL'S MOTHER,
HER NAME IS IRINA, SHE SURVIVED,
BUT BECAUSE OF THE FRAGILITY OF
HER HEALTH RIGHT NOW AND BECAUSE
OF HER INJURIES SHE HAS NOT YET
BEEN TOLD THAT HER DAUGHTER WAS
KILLED.
JOHN?
>> SCOTT McLEAN IN VINNYTSIA,